best-selling author Mitch Albom is
writing a new novel to raise money for
coronavirus relief his popular books of
course include Tuesdays with Maurey
and the five people you meet in heaven
albums new book human touch is free he
is publishing one chapter online every
week for the next eight weeks actually
eight in total readers can make
donations to his charity which is
Detroit Beats kovin 19 and Mitch Albom
joins us from his home in Detroit Mitch
good morning thanks so much for being
with us
welcome Lauren this is quite it this is
quite a it's a great cause that you've
taken on obviously and but you've given
yourself quite a challenge here writing
on demand essentially week by week but
you've ripped this story right from the
headlines I'm hoping you know how this
all ends I was actually going to ask you
I don't know how it ends I'm doing it
one week at a time and it's not the way
I normally write a work of fiction but
you know these are extraordinary times
what made you decide to do this Mitch I
want to help out my city Anthony I mean
Detroit is the hardest hit city after
New York we've got first responders that
are that are dying we've got hospitals
that are overrun and you know I thought
well this is what I do for a living I
sell books so let me write a work of
fiction it's not a big full book but
doesn't be a work of fiction and let me
offer it for free and see if I can get
people around the world I'm blessed to
have readers from all over to help
donate and help our city out so I try to
take a story that I knew I could you
know move around as as the pandemic
continued so it centers on a street
corner in Michigan on one small town
where there's four families living in
four houses and how those four families
sort of interact with each other as the
pandemic grows and how they go from very
neighborly they're starting to become
distrustful some get closer so I'm get
further apart and at the core of it is
this one mysterious eight-year-old boy
who's just recent to the neighborhood
who seems immune to any kind of illness
and as people start to get sick he
sneaks around to their houses and offers
himself to be hugged and and held and
provide this human touch that we miss so
much and then just when he seems to be
the key to the curing the whole thing he
mysteriously disappears and
that I'm really not sure what happened
so you're gonna have to stay with me
week every Friday we put out another
chapter and I'll let you know you're not
a [ __ ] are you right obviously you're
very prolific but you're not used to
having to hit a deadline every week are
you
well the sports writer part of my past
has trained me well for this because I
used to have to write things in five
minutes on deadline for the newspaper
and so this is a little more like that
but no I don't usually write my books
this way I usually chase them to the
publishers as they're going saying let
me add one more sentence let me add my
warm sentence and this is like done with
it done I record it I do it audio
recording with audible and it all has to
be done you know by Monday I'm doing it
right after I'm done with you and then
we start the next chapter all over again
yeah and the eight-year-old character
you mentioned is based in part on an
eight-year-old who's staying at your
house from your from your orphanage the
orphanage that you back in Haiti is that
right yeah ironically he came up from
from from Haiti for physical therapy
he's a handicapped in a way and so he
got caught in the travel ban and so now
we're parents to an eight-year-old and
he's just been an amazing delight he's
he's full of joy his name is Knox in the
book he's little Moses but he provides
such energy and such sunshine for us
being locked in that I realized you know
children are a huge key to people
feeling you know that they're still
hoping this thing so not only is he the
inspiration for the character but for
the audio a version of this which we do
with audible he actually records the
voice of the eight-year-old boy he sits
on my lap and I give him the line and he
does the line he's very good Act
therefore for an eight-year-old Haitian
boy and you can hear him if you listen
to the audio version showed up that's
really great Mitch you you I wanted to
mention you wrote a column recently
there in Detroit titled the Michigan I
know doesn't lose its head in a pandemic
what are you getting at there well I've
been hearing from people around the
country about the protest that was held
here at the Capitol and people are
saying well what's going on in your
state and I would say well it's not our
state that's a thousand or 2,000 cars
that are exercising their First
Amendment right to protest certain
things but in a
10 million people that doesn't
necessarily speak for all of us I think
the majority of people in Michigan while
we're certainly suffering business-wise
and-and-and with tight restrictions I
think are our top preference is to make
sure we don't lose one more soul from
Michigan to this not a grandparent not a
child not a first responder not a doctor
and if that means we have to stay locked
in a little bit longer or endure a
little bit longer if it's gonna save
lives I think that's the way the
majority the state thinks all right all
right Mitch Albom thank you so much for
more information about how to read human
touch you can visit our website at CBS
this morning
dot-com thanks Mitch